hundreds of people are arriving daily at
german reception centers like this one
in Berlin migration was the political
issue in the capital this week and
German Chancellor Angela Merkel made
clear early on that action was needed
quickly is this it's very important that
we now say German efficiency is great
but what we need right now is German
flexibility on some day Germany's
coalition government will debate what
that means in practice the major parties
have been at odds on a number of points
controversially German interior minister
Thomas de Mesilla is proposing to change
the country's constitution he wants to
make it easier for the government to
transfer money for Refugees to local
authorities Social Democrats don't want
to see the constitutional change in
addition Angela Merkel CDU wants
migrants to receive funding for food and
clothing through a voucher system they
oppose cash payments the Social
Democrats disagree it's sort of finding
guns few more than anything this would
just increased bureaucracy we have to be
more flexible right now we need simple
solutions quick decisions and quick
actions but coalition party members do
agree that migrants coming from
countries deemed to be safe should be
promptly sent home fundamental laws
concerning migrants are not expected to
change anytime soon politicians can take
heart from the fact that the country is
largely unfazed by the influx of
migrants polls suggest nearly sixty
percent of Germans are not afraid of
people entering their country and that
could make policy makers a bit more
flexible at their summit on Sunday